lo que me gustaría explorar en este
vídeo es ver si podemos calcular la
derivada de ye con respecto x cuando ya
es igual al seno inverso el seno inverso
de x y como siempre te invito a que le
pongas pausa al vídeo e intentes hacerlo
por tu cuenta aunque ahora te voy a dar
dos pistas no sabemos por supuesto cuál
es la derivada del seno inverso de x
pero sí sabemos cuál es la derivada de
seno de algo así es que podemos regular
esta expresión y entonces derivando
implícitamente encontrar de y en de x
pues recuerda que deje en de x es lo que
estamos buscando básicamente queremos
encontrar la derivada con respecto a x
de esto de aquí
supongo que ya lo intentaste ahora
hagámoslo juntos sigue es igual a seno
inverso de x eso es equivalente a decir
que seno de iu es igual a x seno de y es
igual a equis y ahora ya tenemos
términos a los cuales estamos más
acostumbrados aquí podemos hacer
derivación implícita podemos derivar
ambos lados con respecto a x derivamos
con respecto a x el lado izquierdo y
derivamos con respecto a x el lado
derecho ahora cuál es la derivada con
respecto a x de seno de iu para esto
aplicamos la regla de la cadena esto va
a ser la derivada con respecto a y de
seno de g
qué es
coseno de y que multiplica a la derivada
con respecto a x de iu es decir por d y
én de x lo cual es igual a la derivada
con respecto a x de x que ya sabemos que
es igual a 1 despejando ahora de jane de
x dividiendo ambos lados entre coseno de
y obtenemos que deje en de x es igual a
1 sobre coseno de y sin embargo esto no
nos sirve mucho pues tenemos la derivada
en términos de i y la necesitamos en
términos de x que podemos hacer bien ya
sabemos que x es igual a seno de y
déjame escribir eso x es igual a seno de
g
y aquí tenemos coseno de y en el
denominador si usamos identidades
trigonométricas para escribir esto en
términos de seno de iu estaremos cerca
de nuestro objetivo pues x es igual a
seno de g y esto como lo logramos
bueno si recordamos nuestras identidades
trigonométricas sabemos que seno
cuadrado de i + coseno cuadrado de y
esto es igual a 1 despejamos coseno
cuadrado de y restando seno cuadrado de
ambos lados para obtener que coseno
cuadrado de l es igual a 1 menos seno
cuadrado de ye vamos a despejar coseno
de y sacando raíz cuadrada a ambos lados
con lo cual coseno de iu es igual a la
raíz cuadrada principal de uno menos
seno cuadrado de g
así es que podemos escribir esto como
uno sobre coseno de y que ya vimos que
es la raíz cuadrada de uno menos seno
cuadrado de iu y que ganamos con esto
bueno pues seno de iu es x así es que
esto es igual a equis cuadrada déjame
escribirlo de la siguiente manera para
que lo veamos claramente esto es seno de
iu elevado al cuadrado
así es que esto es igual
1 sobre la raíz cuadrada de 1 - seno del
xx menos x al cuadrado y ya lo tenemos
esta es la derivada con respecto a x de
seno inverso de x la derivada con
respecto a x de seno inverso de x es
igual a 1 sobre la raíz cuadrada de 1 -
x cuadrado quiero que quede muy claro
esto al derivar a ambos lados aquí con
respecto a x obtuvimos que la derivada
de ye con respecto a x es igual a esto
de acá es decir hemos obtenido que la
derivada con respecto a x de seno
inverso de x esto es igual a 1 sobre la
raíz cuadrada de 1 - x cuadrada esta
prueba la puede repetir siempre que te
falle la memoria como suele suceder y
así te familiarizas con este resultado
pero es bueno aprender de esto sobre
todo a medida que avanzas en cálculo y
pudieras encontrarte con esta expresión
y decir ay esa es la derivada de s
inverso de x así esto te habrá sido
sumamente útil